that are working against the best
interests of American citizens so please
welcome Daniel Weber
hello Patriots
I look out at these people and I say I
know what true Americans look like and
I'm seeing them now
I lost friends on September 11th and I'm
here to honor them
I'm Dan weather from AMAC the
association of mature American citizens
but other than that
I'm a nobody
I'm not a celebrity
I'm not famous I'm just a citizen like
you but this citizen has something to
say today
and I'm going to say it
I know that the terrorists who committed
these murderers claimed to be acting on
behalf of their religion Islam
that makes what I'm going to talk about
controversial
I make no apology for this
because I'm exercising my rights as a
citizen
to those to those who may criticize what
I have to say
let me remind all of you
in America we have the right to speak
out when we see something wrong
building the mosque here is wrong
we have the right to protest when we are
insulted
in America
we can speak out against those who take
advantage of our freedom to promote
their own agenda
while they're hurting the families of
the victims of September 11th
the Builders of the mosque claim they're
purely humanitarians
to them I say you cannot force peace and
Harmony into the wounded hearts of those
who suffered from radical Islam
I have a simple message
Kareem am Ralph
wrong page
even Ralph listened to the please listen
to the pleas of the thousands of people
who were here
don't ignore the millions of Americans
throughout the country who agree with us
show us respect
act with dignity and kindness not
bullheadedness
be aware of the Traditions that made up
this great
Nation
think of our Traditions our Traditions
when you make your decisions
despite what the president said
we are a nation
founded and governed by judeo-christian
heritage
and that Heritage has sort of something
it taught us to judge the motives and
the actions of others by the fruit that
those actions bear
as I look upon this sea of people
many of whom
were driven here by anger
I can clearly see the fruits of Iman
Raul's
plans and they are not good
others have questioned where the funds
for the mosque are coming from
others say
what are the secret motives that drives
your aggressive plan
some people question whether you've
supported terrorists like Hamas as some
other mosques in America have done
I don't care
in America
As Americans know we always give folks
the benefit of the doubt
we believe you until you prove us wrong
we believe you are good until you show
us you are bad
Imam you have the power
by making a simple decision
to show Americans that you are
considerate
you are good
by moving the mask to another location
amen Ralph you say your plans for the
mosque are intended as an act of peace
and Harmony if you really mean that if
peace and Harmony are truly your goal
then if that's really your goal then
hear this
all of us here today say with one voice
amen Ralph tear up your plans
tear up your plans even Ralph
tear them up tear them up
should you ignore our please
you'll be clearly showing the people of
this country that you have contempt for
the feelings of those who have lost
their loved ones here
and though you may use conciliary
language the American people will hold
you in contempt
I've been told I gotta end now
so let me end by saying this we implore
you not to build the nask
if you build the mosque and it's three
lines
you will be building a monument to the
terrorists
who murdered innocent people
that mosque will be an ever-present
reminder of what people have done in the
name of Islam
if you build the mosque here you'll be
creating the Divide
between Islam and the other religions
and that'll set us back for years
I ask and I pray you find the courage to
change your plans it's not going to be
easy but it will be a true sign of peace
to all the wonderful people here today I
know your legs are tired
remember God has blessed America
let us remember to honor God by living
the way he wants us to live and God
bless you all
just remember you drove this story
remember that you made this story the
media ignored this story since late
December but you see how they put this
guy up from Florida I'm not gonna even
say his name then making him the story
trying to conflate the two just so that
you know you drove this story you cannot
stop they're waiting for you to stop you
can't stop this is the only thing that's
going to stop the victory mosque moving
on